[Music]
the bullets can't find I see little
children my own grandchildren are in the
line of fire July for forty years and
now I feel that now is the time stand up
and be counted
a lot of these kids have been through
more than most adults within sixty
seventy years of living for a young
person to be out on the street and
witness one of their friends going in
front of them is not something that most
adults will ever experience we wrote
joint to get information of this quality
in this quantity in one go is phenomenal
yessir al goldstein has been a rabbi in
california for more than 30 years last
week a gunman walked into the synagogue
the rabbi built and shot dead lori k a
long-standing member of the congregation
who put herself between the gunman and
the rabbi rabbi goldstein was shot in
the hand and lost a finger in the attack
I spoke to him about it worried your
mission in life is complete this is what
you did in your life and this were you
doing in your afterlife her life was
selfless her life was kindness laughter
sweetness always being there fathers and
she was the type of a person that you
always wanted to be around she was
always upbeat
she always had all the information you
ever needed she always found out all the
information you ever needed
she was my point to person Laurie what's
going on there because she was involved
in everyone's life she was a loyal kind
friend a type of friend that you really
when you ask yourself so many friends do
you really have that our loyal real
friends and Laurie and I would talk
about that a lot about the idea of
loyalty she was a loyal friend
she died
in a house of worship she is a martyr
the only reason why she died was because
she was Jewish and this baseless hatred
that killed her
cut her life in short she was just 60
years old she has one daughter Hannah
she looked forward to walking her down
the aisle we spoke about her we laugh
about it how I'll be officiating at
Hannah's wedding that's all she wanted
is for our only child for her to work at
them that I own and your life was taken
away from her just because of pure
hatred and that has to stop
I know you spoke to the president how
does that hate stop how does president
had a society how did all of us prevent
stop and end these ideas that people
like this have or firstly we have to
acknowledge that anti-semitism is
overtly out there it's not a myth it's
not something of the past the Holocaust
75 years ago did not stop it's
continuing and it's getting worse and
it's just not right
haven't we learned from history the site
that I saw the Saturday morning and my
temple is a picture out of Kristen
laughs that have a program in Europe
that is not supposed to happen in 2018
we we built that Center to be a home of
love of warmth a synagogue any house of
worship is your sanctuary it's really
supposed to be safe it's where you lean
on each other's shoulders you cry you
laugh you celebrate you sing you dance
you do your life cycles there you don't
come there to get killed and shot them
murdered for no reason
the bullets came flying I see little
children my own grandchildren are in the
line of fire
I was the line of fire the shooter was
aiming right at me miraculously I was
speared today could have been my funeral
but God had different plans for me
my whole life has changed I'm a new
person I don't know what the future
holds for me but I'm so great that I'm
alive and Laurie is not and I'm gonna
keep her name alive I'm gonna keep her
legacy alive
[Music]
they are childhood friends united by a
tragic bond as haemophiliac children at
trololo college in Hampshire in the 70s
and 80s they were infected with HIV or
hepatitis C in contaminated blood
products dispensed at an NHS run clinic
they are among just 16 out of 86 boys
still alive when Steve Nichols gave
evidence to the public inquiry he made
good on a 40-year old promise but with
the life forty years and now I feel that
now is the time to stand up and be
counted
and I felt obliged to stand up for all
my friends and all the other attendees
at Law College in autumn 8016 phonetic
always attended only 16 survived today
and I'm looking
one of the 16 an astonishing number is
that I have retired to see an HIV
ultimately that code most of those
deaths those various strains of
hepatitis HIV and vCJD was all pushed
through that college to school boys
between the ages of 8 and 16 we were
clean young boys you will hear the
expression parts previously uninfected
patients verging haemophilia acts
basically we were guaranteed to be clean
we were all prepubescent we've never
been sexually active we've never been
exposed to drugs and none of us had ever
taken alcohol they go and see that blood
was clean so they could inject us and
test us as and when required and you
believe there was a deliberate trialing
of these absolutes product absolutely I
do
it was weekly fortnightly they were
taking blood who never told why and it
was large quantities of blood for
testing for various
diseases various infections you've lost
so many friends how important is you
that this inquiry pursued that line of
Investigation absolutely I'm standing
here today not only represents my I
myself or my own putting my own personal
views across but I feel compelled to put
the views across of the 69 boys that are
no longer there this and tell their
story and I think I've told it today in
the free that spaghettini all they were
starting to die and the link between
hemophilia hepatitis and HIV had been
made and we realized that this is
serious and it's highly likely but this
is going to affect us and some of us are
not going to come out this alive we made
a pact that when he does hit the fan and
he will hit the fan the person's the
people who are left which stand up and
tell the story as it was and tell the
truth and I forget justice like you've
done that today absolutely
I'd be proud I hope so I hope so we live
together we ate together we learned
together we played together we grew
together they were more than friends
they became like brothers liked peers
siblings even so that bond is much
greater than friendship will never be
broken for for sixteen here today
they should be 89 we've discovered that
a growing number of children are being
excluded from mainstream education for
drugs and violence why did you get
excluded from your previous school turn
our rocket teacher trying a rock weighed
cocaine hands up if you think it's easy
to get drugs we've been given rare
access to two pupil Referral Units known
as Prue's which are set up to educate
excluded children the truth is behind
each person that comes to us
there's a story and I think our job here
rather than just continuing where they
left off from in a mainstream
environment as in strange when English
lesson straight into a math lesson
straight into a science lesson isn't
gonna work and it hasn't worked which is
largely why they're here in the first
place so it's about trying to rewind
that story and strip back some of those
layers to identify the root cause of
some of the problems particularly
bereavement loss of a parent I think
it's a common common issue that we come
across and those young people from
single-parent families particularly when
there's no positive male role model
often either try and be that man of the
house themselves or seek seek a sense of
belonging from elsewhere and it's those
young people that are then valuable to
whether it be gang activity and other
ways like that so yeah I mean like I say
bereavement low self-esteem and issues
around friendship and family whether it
be drugs as well that there were a few
common themes there when you strip back
you can identify it that areas that we
can change and we can better with time
yeah and looking at the scale of the
problem I mean how would you define how
big the trauma if you like that they've
been through a lot of these kids just to
sort of put it into perspective you like
what some of these kids have been
through I think a lot of these kids have
been through more than most adults would
in 6070 years of living if I'm being
honest I think that for a young person
to go to bed one night and wake up in
the morning and one of their parents had
passed away in the same house that they
are in or for a young person to witness
the levels of domestic violence that
they may witness taking place in home or
for a young person to be out on the
street and see one of their friends
witness one of their friends die in
front of them is not something that most
adults will ever experience and when we
understand and when we like I said
before strip it back to really identify
the traumatic events that they've been
through I'm not saying it excuses the
behavior we see later in school but it
shows help provide some form of
reasoning as to why young person may
behave in a way that's not considered
normal do you think that mainstream
schools could do more are able to do
more to actually deal with some of those
challenges before it gets to this stage
I think the sad truth is that mainstream
schools want to do more and I think the
issue is that fighter is also
perspective it's just not always
possible and that's sad because we're
talking about the lives of young people
I'm here in Srilanka almost two weeks on
from the Easter Sunday bombings against
churches and hotels that left almost 250
people dead
a massive investigation is underway with
a number of suspects still on the loose
a key line of inquiry is the link
between the suicide bombers and Islamic
state I spoke earlier to the president
so do you think there could be a foreign
mastermind behind this attack it's not a
homegrown plot below me the issues are
some garlic citynet irregular quran
quran metal on CD melody of a southern
girl our game Evandro gotten in Category
want impunity am only night inuyasha
many servi dissolution 11:30 tomorrow
with own katakana t-top ahead illumine
at the internal into along this dinner
but do you think we've given the fall of
the is caliphate that the attacks in sri
lanka signal a new campaign by Islamic
state to launch terrorist attacks around
the world is song returning meet
appearance on you've got some time until
a suitable colony does the hot on pardon
me
probable rock all over Europe England
any salmon gay a loot salad sumikko a
looted hosaka
to Cydia Queen Apple want a Killa
second it on the wrong Martina DNA
company me Dima gave me need Islamic
Amira talk some high prahara nilgiri
Molokini Li the yes Seungyeon is Arabic
is Montana meet a better bigger category
than an air although I believe in
prahara Brazil a twin name any sour
anima mean Lima a bogus amo I mean in
the hospital one of our regular faces
here on Sunrise Michael Booker from The
Daily Express he's been writing about a
very personal experience and that is his
father's battle with motor neurone
disease a horrible disease which slowly
weakens the muscles in the body
including those used for breathing while
Michael says the experience made him
question the idea of a cyst
dying he couldn't put his socks on he
couldn't shave I mean there was one time
when I was helping him shave a few weeks
before he went into the hospital for the
last time and he was saying look I can't
do this anymore I hated this and it was
it was horrible to see him like that
because he was so full of life and it
was upsetting me mother it was upsetting
all of us but he hated but at the same
time he talked about how he wanted to
end it now as I said it has helped me
question assisted dying and what happens
with that but it's not to say that he
would have taken up the option if the
option had been there for him I think it
would have been a comfort for him and I
think that's the point I was trying to
make in the piece or I'd like to if it
didn't expand it pieces no one wants to
die no one wants to die but and he
didn't I mean look at him he was full of
life big smile on his face all the time
you really look like him and no I think
if you have that option at the moment if
you help someone to die it's a
manslaughter charge isn't it whereas I
think if someone like him knew that the
people he'd left behind if their system
with dying wouldn't get prosecuted there
wouldn't be a problem they say I don't
think my dad would have taken up the
option in between the points cussed with
him because obviously motor neurone
disease affected your dad yeah affected
you particular your mom who is his carer
as a family did you discuss it because
I'd imagine it would be even if you
might be thinking it's a very difficult
thing to start a conversation on it kind
of comes up in like love in individual
conversations with certain members of
the family and you're talking hushed
tones about it but like I said the one
time he talked to me about it when I was
shaving him and I had an electric razor
rounding because he couldn't he couldn't
get into the nooks and cranny's with his
handheld razor anymore and he just said
I can't do this anymore
I hate it it's not me and then five
minutes later he set with me grant with
his granddaughter my daughter and he's
he's loving himself again he loving it
again but then there's the moment where
I can't go to the toilet and he can't
eat properly because he can't hold his
knife and fork anymore and he loved his
food and that's why he lived for his
meal at the end of the day just looked
forward to his big day at the end of the
day no there's 5,000 people in this
country at any one time got this and I'm
lucky that I can talk about this but
there's a lot of families out there and
since I wrote it yesterday there's been
quite a few getting in touch saying that
they're in this wilderness they're all
bubbled and they've got these families
and I'm just looking that I'll be able
to like hopefully shine the light on
those but for those people
the second cyclone to hit Mozambique in
six weeks has left the country
struggling to cope thousands of homes
have been destroyed and many roads are
underwater
now relentless rain has caused delays in
getting help through
[Music]
how is Mozambique faring after these
these two natural disasters in six weeks
well it's it's very difficult for us you
know but you know nobody is not always
prepared to to be with these kind of
programs we are trying to do our best
while sitting on a tranquil beach in
northern cyprus three years ago the
writer Christie left Eric was struck by
the realization that a short pop across
the water the war in Syria I was tearing
that country apart she travelled to
Athens as a consequence to volunteer in
a Women's and Children's Center the
decision that allowed her to witness
firsthand the resilience of the human
spirit there I was visiting my dad that
lives on the far east side of Cyprus and
as I sat there and I thought I'm so safe
here and just across the water so
there's a war going on there's bombs
falling children dying and I just
couldn't stop thinking about it so when
I went back to the UK I contacted a few
organizations and made my way to Athens
because I speak Greek and I worked at
mother and Children's Center well it was
actually a Women's and Children's Center
and the women and children were coming
from the camps to the center to have
warm showers there was a play area for
the children to play and there was an
area for new mothers and often some of
these young babies were born on the
journey so it was my job to just be
there for them help as much as I could
but the more I was there and the more I
understood about the traumas that people
had been through the sadness the loss I
it really kind of got inside me and it
just kept going around in my head
and I realized that perhaps I might want
to write about this so I started to
interview people in the square I started
to do that were they happy to talk about
it some people were I actually realized
that many people wanted to tell their
stories you know I'd ask people how did
you get here what was your journey and I
realized that a lot of people actually
wanted to be heard of course there were
language barriers there were some people
that spoke English but I also had a
translator who worked with me at the
centre and I just really felt that
people wanted to be heard yeah what
common denominators emerged were the
themes that you could identify after a
while or was each story different
the stories were different of course but
you know it was just that this sense of
displacement profound loss and this idea
of how do you continue with your life
when you've lost so much and what
happens with the way you are with the
people you care about the most in the
world when you've suffered so much
trauma so I heard stories about people
that were trying to reconnect with their
families or people that could no longer
speak because they'd had suffered so
much loss so all these kind of
experiences and stories got into my mind
I remember there was a there was a
little baby at the center that he'd just
been born he was absolutely tiny to the
point where he looked like a little twig
and the mother was so traumatized that
she couldn't because she couldn't
produce milk and the baby wouldn't take
the formula so we were worried that the
baby was going to die and so all we
could do was just offer her tea and
biscuits we didn't have a food license
so we offered her team biscuits we sat
with her she didn't want to talk she
would just sit there and stare into
space but we sat there with her every
day she had a warm shower every day we
gave her tea and biscuits every day and
eventually she started to produce milk
the baby started to feed and after a few
days ease eyes open to the world and it
was that kind of experience of seeing
that baby open his tiny little eyes to
the world after we'd been so afraid that
he might die that kind of made me
understand that kind of resilience of
the human spirit the strength that we
actually do have and what happens when
we work together as well
a mystery benefactor has given designer
clothes worth around 50,000 pounds to a
charity shop in Kent the items were left
at the mind store in Tunbridge Wells I
spoke to the manager
Alison Homewood about the surprise
donation we were overjoyed any donation
is gratefully received and that is what
has kept us here for 20 years but to get
a donation of this quality in this
quantity in one go is phenomenal stuff
inside there is worth it was just great
yes we then have to spend quite a long
time looking at the prices of it because
despite what people think we don't pluck
a figure out of the air we have to see
what is sold for originally on the
website of the designer if it's still
available where it is available and then
we look on various online auction sites
to see what people will actually pay for
the item it's been absolutely incredible
we've had a lady communal Saturday and
her daughter had seen us on the website
in Australia and she had told her mum to
come down buy a dress and her mum
dutifully wolf to dress for a couple of
hundred pounds somebody came down from
Cambridge and it's just been great
people have the word to spread and the
important thing is hopefully when this
is all calmed down a little bit we're on
people's radar now they didn't know we
were here
now they do and they've all said all we
will be back now we know the amazing
stuff you have not just these items but
this stop generally no shop is of a very
very high quality and now people
appreciated that know where we are
they've all said they can come back
you